-Performing "In Color"
from My Morning Jacket's
self-titled album,
here is Jim James.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ You gotta admit
it looks better in color ♪
♪ All the rainbow appears ♪
♪ You gotta believe
it sounds better in color ♪
♪ All the spectrum to hear ♪
♪ There's more to life ♪
♪ Than just black and white ♪
♪ So many shades in between ♪
♪ Yeah, there's more to life ♪
♪ Than what's yours
or what's mine ♪
♪ Oh, and I wish everyone
could agree ♪
♪ In color ♪
♪ Yeah, in color ♪
♪ You gotta admit
it sounds better in color ♪
♪ All the spectrum appears ♪
♪ You gotta admit
it looks better in color ♪
♪ All the rainbow to hear ♪
♪ Yeah, there's more to life ♪
♪ Than just black and white ♪
♪ So many shades in between ♪
♪ Yeah, there's more to life ♪
♪ Than what's yours
or what's mine ♪
♪ Oh, and I wish everyone
could agree ♪
♪ In color ♪
♪ Oh, in color ♪
♪ Yeah, in color ♪
♪ You gotta admit
it sounds better in color ♪
♪ All the rainbow appears ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]